they're epically cool and living the
lives that we all strive to live
for decades the san dieguito boogie
board club has met
every week to catch some waves together
and today
they're here to tell us about it so
please welcome
fran dyer krista stahl carol
german and charlotte gambrell
we're so excited to speak with you guys
today
um fran and krista you're the founders
of this whole operation
may i ask how did it start um well it
started in 2002.
krista and i were at a weight watchers
meeting
and the weight watcher meeting was right
on the ocean we were
at the top of the bluff and we had 150
steps to walk down to the ocean
and so i said krista after the meeting's
over why don't we start going in the
ocean
why don't we grab some boogie boards and
just go and play
and three other women joined us and we
began
and that is 19 years ago and krista tell
us
all about your experience with it
well it's pretty much the same um the
club that we belong to
is a newcomers club and i was new
to the area i retired and i had re
relocated and so it really was a nice
meeting up and it's been consistent ever
since then fran i think
you've kept me going and and perhaps
me too carol you joined the club
15 years ago after a boogie boarding
injury
but it didn't stop you can you tell us
about that
well i also was new to the area and
really didn't know very many people
and i live right on the ocean
i can look out my window and see it any
time i want
uh but i wasn't going in because i had
broken
a number of bones boogie boarding in
hawaii wow
these ladies when i got to know them
through the
big club the newcomers club said come on
in the ocean with us and
krista was really one of my heroes
because
she's a little older than i am and i
thought if krista can do this i can do
it too
so they kind of talked me back into the
water
and i'm so glad they did because it
keeps us
young and healthy i love this so much
because i feel like
so many times people just get boring as
they get older and they don't try new
things and i know charlotte you're
you're one of the most the most senior
of the boogie boarders right
tell us how you got into this well
actually i wish i'd known
about this group earlier yeah i boogie
boarded
pretty much with my teenage children we
used to use the
canvas uh things and then all of a
sudden somebody invented the boogie
board and oh my golly what a wonderful
thing that was
so i bought it for grandchildren and
then i decided that
hey i'm the one who really loves the
boogie board
so i've been doing it ever since i think
i'm on my fourth board
what's the best thing about it i just
have to ask what really
rocks it for you charlotte well in a
very short time
i feel like my brain is alive i'm alive
and life is worth living you know it
doesn't take
much time in that water to feel that way
boarding boarding is a wonderful sport
up until
i keep thinking this is my last year but
i'm still doing it
you know friends are everything and the
way that you guys
show up for each other and for life in
general
is just inspiration to us all and thank
you for coming to talk
here today with us so that we can look
to you guys on
how we're supposed to live our lives
thank you for having us exactly
thank you so much we love you thank you
dan
and krista and carol and charlotte
thank you for showing us away
and cowabunga we're coming to get ya
i'll see you on the waves ladies
thank you so much
you